please join me in welcoming professor
Gregory Crane for a talk entitled
humanities and digital age
well I would I'm amazed that you are all
here inside when we have one of the few
incredibly beautiful days
in New England and but I have to say I
beat you out I was on Long Beach Island
yesterday morning
and cut short my visit to an undisclosed
location where I was writing to come
here to be with you today so I'm going
to and I have a lot of whoops way more
slides than I'm going to get through so
while you may if you you may want to
close your eyes if you don't want to
have a seizure as some of these things
go by and so yeah I have a bunch of odd
titles when I first started studying
classics I thought about what it would
be like to be something like the Elliot
professor of Greek at my home department
I wasn't prepared when they asked me if
I would be the Winnick chair of
technology and entrepreneurship but that
is actually a wonderful position to be
in because it essentially gives me a
license to do technology to do cool
stuff and to cause trouble
which of the two things I think I'm
licensed for and I've also been elected
a humble professor of digital humanities
in the computer science department for
Leipzig Germany and in that capacity I
believe that I am there to help
defend European culture against those
anglo-american I know all of your tricks
so you can't get anything by me and I'll
start just with the the question of
digital humanities and I find it
tremendously ironic that I am have been
given a chair in digital humanities
because I don't believe in the digital
humanities particularly I tend to see it
as a separate niche field and as a safe
place to to sequester disturbing ideas
and so friend of mine gave a lecture at
a sort of important university near by
me in Boston a couple of years ago
millions of dollars work on data mining
and the English department showed up and
my friend said that's really cool that's
the true humanities and they walked away
and said it's got nothing to do with me
and probably true in the sense of what
they have been doing the practices which
they have inherited it probably doesn't
fit into that but you know so I tend to
think the issue really is that ideas now
flow through a digital space we depend
upon you to preserve these ideas those
of you in this case thing those of you
who work in the library and and you know
when we worry well what happens when we
lose our digital books well when we lose
our bank accounts and our medical
records and society collapses we'll have
bigger problems to worry about it is
that the world is digital now and this
civilization forever and irrevocably I
think so the real question is what does
that mean for the humanities it's not
that the digital humanities are this
little cute field over there doing their
thing it's that the world is we swim and
breathe a world of digital data and what
are the implications for that okay now
there couple of traditions I think it's
I think about and I'm really fascinated
not just because I've been offered a
position in Germany but with the German
tradition of universities which really
shaped the American University's German
American history from he doesn't begin
in 1917
it begins in 1817 when Edward Everett
received the was the first American to
receive a PhD in a German university and
was the first of many who came back and
shaped these universities largely on the
German model and the one of my heroes
Vilhelm von Humboldt established the
University of Berlin now named after him
and his brother Alexander and his view
was that the instructor is not there to
serve the student there in the
university rather both student and
instructor are there to serve this a job
which is untranslatable knowledge
whatever and that this is by serving
this higher goal you advance education
and that students don't go to the
University to take big lecture classes
to get received wisdom that is not
worthy of a university in his view that
is somewhere else
you go there to create and to learn how
to develop your own authentic voice in
collaboration with others there's
another tradition that you can document
here for example liberal education of
the upper class is the great panacea for
present and future evils and of course
classical scholarship is still what it
was a characteristic of the higher
classes in this country and I should say
in this particular book classical
scholarship is not writing books it's
being able to compose Greek and Latin
verse because any annual Drudge can
learn enough to write books Germans can
do that is very anti German but one has
to have gone to a appropriate schools
and started early to be able to do Greek
and Latin verse composition thus it's
its class replication and our
universities combined both of these
traditions and obviously one of the
challenges we have that you have an
elite institution is to think about that
my way I think about it is my son had an
opportunity to go to Tufts where I teach
for zero dollars it cost nothing if we
done it that way and he got into we had
the bad manners of getting into another
university also a 25 minute walk from
my home that you know was different
so tops ranks about thirty who float
around somewhere there it's a very good
university and so I'm spending two
hundred and forty thousand dollars or
whatever it is for him to get the name
of said other University because when in
you know at the end of his life in his
obituary it'll say you know educated at
this particular place pure class
formation and I pay you know I'm paying
for it
you know us that's that's a couple of
years less more work a lot more work to
retire so where do we where does the US
where do the our institutions stand with
respect to these different traditions
and other questions what are the
humanities stand and so I have a
parochial question and I hope I am part
of my purpose of coming here and talking
is that help me in this so if you have
five years with a lot of money in the
humanities and the prospect of getting a
lot more money or organizing a lot more
money what would you do because that is
kind of my situation right now and I
think the thing I want to frame for you
orphis eyes for you is that it's not a
question you know often digital
humanities are represented implicitly as
ways to write more articles and books
and put more stuff in JSTOR or project
Muse and well you know maybe that's
that's one thing you can do but you know
what are your real goals and for me the
question is how as humanists I interpret
my goal is to be how do we interns the
intellectual life of humanity you may
have different goals you know that's
fine this is what I interpret to be the
purpose of us are the humanities of
humanities departments then that might
drop down to how do we help people think
about particular languages or cultures
that we study and in my case that would
be how do we get more people we're
interacting with Greek and Latin sources
in whatever capacity and then questions
how what are the metaphors that you use
we describe what our purposes are we one
might be a global
book of letters which is a very
appealing one though Eurocentric and
sort of elitist but another might be
thinking in terms of a dialogue among
civilizations the UN called for a
dialogue among civilizations inspired by
then President or Iranian president
Khatami Mohammad Khatami and that was
2001 so the UN a year for the dialogue
among civilizations was short-circuited
in a dramatic fashion that doesn't mean
that only means that the dialogue is
more important even though we know when
they're storming the embassy a dialogue
may not work very well this is a
long-term fundamental process okay now
in terms of of what we work with it's
not we don't really work with books or
even artifacts often it's data and often
might you know when I talk to my program
officers at NSF y'all say don't keep
them as just text up let's we all text
as easy
give us something interesting like you
know pictures or movies and you know I
have to say well no it's not quite that
simple and you know the object and a
thing I and this is for you as a library
audience or those of you from libraries
is that the object of interest is not a
book often certain for me never and the
people I work with never per se you know
it's almost always the books I mean the
words in the books so if you want a
catalog and the European digital library
is Europe beyond has given up you know
the catalog model all together and I
think it's a good thing but I need to be
able to track every version every word
in every version of every source in
every language over time it's a big
Network that's the object of interest
that I start with some people go deeper
into into paleography but for me I'll
settle for the word okay
we have say to have a million or a
million documents a thousand words each
you get something like a true actually
good a true
you got tin Bell you get like it's
really a billion words
but up and if you anchor gate everything
is probably like more like a trillion
words of data hanging around in various
formats the hockey trust contains 400
languages for other languages I mean so
that's that's a lot that's more than you
can study much less master and we have
all sorts of text bearing objects that
we have to deal with including
archaeological objects orbiting like
inscriptions and and and vases
we have texts in multiple languages that
are and multiple versions over time and
we've done we've done a very good job of
creating an infrastructure an initial
infrastructure to address intellectual
or physical access so I want to see
something and physical access is
foundational and so here's one of my
favorite projects Digital Walters
because it's Creative Commons license
data and they don't try to impose their
own interface on it which i think is the
best way to go in both cases and so you
can go fine wonderful arabic documents
and you can get as much detail as you
would want you could read every single
line every character on that page and if
you know a classical Arabic and you
understand what classical Arabic books
on logic say you're set you know oh
that's physical access that's not it
electoral access intellectual access is
okay now what I've got this and this is
the great challenge and opportunity I'll
give you another example this is the
venit is a manuscript produced at or in
the 10th century in Constantinople and
rescued or carried to Venice about a hop
skip and a jump in front of the Turkish
the final collapse and it is an
extraordinary that is the most important
manuscript of Homer has thus Kolya it
has also interesting things going on
with it and you know not many people can
read this not many people have access to
it the whole thing has however been
scanned at ridiculously high resolution
and
what we discovered is that now instead
of having a Staller or expert go through
and do this by hand there are teams of
undergraduate researchers at Holy Cross
which is the best classics Department in
the United States best program I should
say and Furman University in South
Carolina and University of Houston
collaborate in editing this and that's
kind of an impossible task as this
applies paragraph it implies knowledge
and interest and energy that I assumed
was not possible when I get depressed as
a classicist which is like daily I try
to on Friday afternoons I will drive to
Wooster and watch the Holy Cross
manuscript club working volunteering 10
to 20 of them on Friday afternoons to
work without credit and without money on
publishing new manuscripts of Homer the
Homer multi text project is in some ways
the most I think it's the most
interesting project in the country with
which I'm familiar because it is so
impossible man I would never believe
that these students would work on this
that anything is the models will be
flying from my perspective and it is
also an existence proof if you can do
this for these this Greek manuscript you
can do it for anything because it's
really hard now more generally we face
the fact as I alluded to the past this
hyper lingual multilingual is when
you're Swiss and you speak a lot of
languages and make everybody else feel
inferior
but hyper lingual is when is when you
just goes beyond biology and you have to
be Robbie the robot or something to even
consider interacting with all these
languages a hyperlink Abel is when
you're it's out of hand and you can't
possibly learn all these languages and
so we now have millions of books with
400 languages the question is how do we
get meaning out of them how do we
actually exploit that in ways that we've
not been thinking about I think we're
discovering a new world and you know
something a dramatic picture here but
this is
an unclear picture of a map from the the
Marciano Library in Venice that a little
more clear here it's been flipped
because it's actually got south on top
but this is a 1450 the 1450 ish a map of
the world by Fra Mauro and I point out
that this is a coherent space before the
Europe realized it was encountering the
new world and it is a inconceivably
large space a space we don't really
understand we understand bits and pieces
of it we have a bunch of lamp posts
where we've studied what we can see
but these lamp posts are very
disconnected and very ethnocentric and
this new world is a subset of a broader
intellectual perspective and you should
all be very proud I was actually shocked
I was walking into the library today and
I looked up I said oh my god that's the
sort of the program that we're
interested in and you guys Yale whoever
did this I got to find out before I
leave today when this was put together
and why this is an extraordinary thing
you probably never looked at because it
contains not not just the world I just
showed it starts with Native American
Egyptian hieroglyphics Kanaya form and
Hebrew Arabic and Greek Chinese and
Mayan
so it includes the new world and you
know is an estate they don't have
Sanskrit in there maybe I missed it but
it basically ideas they're all connected
it's not just Greek and Latin it's
everything the global culture and it's a
wonderful and it's really wonderful
cheered me up
entirely today so you know and this is
but to go back to this other world it's
not a static world or a made-up world
this is a map representing the travels
of Marco Polo and eben Battuta of whom
most of you probably have never heard
but was an Arabic traveler and when you
learn Arabic in the you know it's a
standard textbook that does use the
United States you discover and the first
reading in volume to that image Battuta
lapped a Marco Polo and was a lot cooler
than he
and you guys never heard of him too so
but this is this represents the fact
that you have networks this is a partial
representation of networks of exchange
operative in the in the Middle Ages and
offered it before that that extend down
into Africa sub-saharan Africa into
Southeast Asia in the Middle East China
and noticed like Germany France England
really aren't part of a mainland there
they're kind of off on the backwater but
this is this world is a world that has a
long history and that's the world the
object of study not just an isolated
piece but individual pieces as parts of
larger systems and the question is who
is your audience you know when I grew up
I was trained to believe that my
audience consisted of about 50 people in
the world who would ever read anything I
wrote and they're the ones who would
write me write for me for tenure they
would and promotion they would invite me
to give talks and so on and screw
everybody else and you know that's
basically the mindset that we inherited
and I believe it was it's a
representative mindset of certainly many
academic communities and so the question
is is that really the audience you want
that's the only audience you could reach
30 years ago is you write a book it's
gonna go in here or 500 places or a
thousand places like this so who you
know why worry about it why not just
speak in encode to other people who know
what you're talking about
but right now or a year ago you know
supposedly there were 2.3 billion
net-net users in the world then as 1/3
of living breathing humanity and it is
scattered all around the world now do
you want to write don't you want to go
right for JSTOR and project muse and
other subscription services that have
the imprimatur of your University and to
write for your for your academic solely
for your academic colleagues or do you
want to reach a global audience you'll
want to reach do something different in
the world and you know you make your own
just you can sort of infer what my
decision is but
by the way freeze that question now say
you wanted to go deal with a modest and
Eurocentric beginning with like eight
modern and twenty historical languages
so basically anyone speaking that it was
the six human languages plus plus German
and Italian and then below I have a
number of fuzzy historical languages and
this is a starting point to that big
picture and one other way of thinking
about it is you might start with popular
culture the way people actually
encounter the past a much underrated
movie I have to say I've probably taught
it and watched it the last year
you might start here or here this is the
Chinese Wikipedia page for this for
Alexander the Great and so someone's in
the middle of China and they speak
Chinese and that's what they speak
that's what they understand
encounter there's a this is interesting
I would like to know more about this
person Alexander the Great
how do they do it where do they go the
challenge for classicists for those of
us who study the ancient world is to
design an infrastructure such that the
person who speaks Hindi or Arabic or you
know whatever and doesn't necessarily
speak French English much let's munch
Truman an Italian could get as start
here and end up there in the sources you
know not in your potted history but in
the data in those sources now this is a
challenging topic and so you'll not be
surprised if I turn for wisdom to
Homearama
I published on the Odyssey after all and
I think what would you find from that
it's like it's really hot this is really
terrifying so this is this is what I've
just described isn't really in its
feasible you could build it you could
build up right now but it's a lot of
work and a lot of work to make it to do
it better questions where'd you get the
labor well you have clever systems
advanced researchers library
professionals citizens scholars who I
will not talk about today but I'll
emphasize student research and a lab
culture and this goes back to the home
or multi text and we know where'd you
get the labor kids are lazy you know
lazy bums they don't do anything well
you know here is a blog from a wonderful
book called reality is broken by Jane
McGonigal and the guy's got a great
quote to get to level up to the top of
rule to Warcraft where you're really
cruising and having fun supposedly it
takes in the average order of magnitude
500 hours of unpaid labor to do
interesting things for an artificial
world you give me five those 500 hours
that's that's 30 weeks that's a year of
study and 15 hours a week you give me
500 hours of study on the craziest
hardest language you could imagine and
now give you a bunch of people who
really know that language better than
they do they learned it when they spend
500 hours with me thinking about what
they're gonna have for dinner is I drone
on or as I'm asking questions around the
room how do you get this and this that
anyway that the amount of time people
spend on games is documented elsewhere
okay now what resources do you have
restoral languages in the US I was
shocked when I looked at the Modern
Language Association study of a survey
of who studies what languages when I
analyzed what historical languages were
studied Greek Latin and Hebrew they were
only 11 languages have more than 50
enrollments in the country that they
could track him and they may be
untracked but that's the numbers that
came up with and when you aggregate it
you find that Greek and Latin account
for more than 75 percent of all
historical language Romans in the
country
um you toss in hee
Biblical Hebrew you get to 95% so all of
your Sanskrit your class go up Arabic
your classical Chinese Yorkin and
foreign languages have enrollments in
the hundreds put another way you drop
two orders of magnitude something that
looks like this this is not a curve this
is it this is you take a bowling Bowl
and you throw it off a building and let
it crash this is the way this is the
distribution of enrollments now this is
not a representation of human intimate
and it is a representation of this is a
friend of mine who's a Dean so you know
you think you have five people who want
to study Coptic you know can we throw a
party call the papers you know it's
you've succeeded you know you have it
you've you've engaged human interest in
the past in a magnificent way but this
is the person allocating resources you
know and that are scarce and he wants
bigger classes because it's it's not
efficient for them and it's and this is
like a bad pyramid application
intellectual not some fat you some some
Philistine so now we know from what you
know like Amazon iTunes you know various
other sources this is the distribution
of human interests it's a long tail and
essentially what this means is that our
universities are brick and mortar you
know bookstores with limited inventory
you can only put stuff on the shelf
that's going to sell a certain number of
units and thus we're not matching
ourselves to the what is that what are
really the interests of students so one
of the questions how do you get from
here to something like this where you
are able to foster to engage human
interest and foster the things people
care about which will get you I believe
probably more engaged more learning
going on so this is kind of a weird dual
strategy and if you want to have a sort
of global vision of the past you have to
build up their capacity to work on Greek
and Latin
we're all your students are right now
you can't justify the enrollments there
not enough enrollments to pay for
specializing for search of the classical
Arabic yet and so you have to do it and
do it in a really cosmopolitan way not
in the normal narrow way that we tend to
do it you have to think act locally
designed globally you might say Greek is
a great place that Greek and Latin agree
places to start the greco-roman world is
a whole nother talk here is as much it's
not doesn't include much of Germany it's
not really Northern European as my my
friend and colleague here at Yale
Dimitri Bhutto's likes to say the West
begins at the Hindukush
and in fact that is where the in the
greco-roman world extends and you have
most people in that in that space today
speak Arabic
I'm not European languages you know
here's your thing and so you've got to
build up develop an infrastructure with
what we might call a virtuous cycle of
learning and contribution or people
aren't just typing in fixing typos they
are learning their their subjects by
making contributions and they have to
make contributions we have like a
billion words of lack we have so much
data in front of us so many sources as
you we would never have enough
professors and librarians to do it all
traditionally you need new methods for
language here's a tool embedded in a
browser where it will replace words in
your newspaper articles with Arabic or
whatever language you're studying but
this is there are different ways of
interacting with language and I'm just
gonna flip through you know this is
they're not over all of you or
passionately interested in the study of
Greek and Latin but well I also say this
is this what you're looking at is a tree
structures representing alternative
views of a sentence the hollow sentence
construe this is what art classes has
been arguing about first forever and
this is also the genome for language
study so the way if you're doing serious
linguistics nowadays you have to go take
a corpus and annotate it richly and then
analyze the patterns to come out
is also something machines don't do very
well and in fact it's exactly and if
students if a person can do this well
then we have pretty good preliminary
evidence not just presuppositions that
they could read the language well so you
have if you you have a situation where
students can learn the language Storting
by analyzing pre analyze text men when
they get good enough whom they level up
in a gaming space and scholarship is
always a game you were level up by
getting a PhD then they can start
contributing it's a very different
dynamic than the one I experienced this
is just an example of a class where we
looked at Greek and Arabic and half the
class knew Greek and half the class knew
Arabic and everybody worked with both
texts and I don't have time to go into
that in detail questions of how do you
keep score and again a lot of this these
contributions of scholarship also assess
learning simultaneously you kind of get
both at once you get opportunities to
edit and translate the gazillions of
documents that have never been
translated never will be and this these
are wonderful ways of of taking a
medieval Latin class for example and
saying we're not just going to give you
an exam and give you something less than
a hundred percent if you do a good job
we will publish the Trent little
translations you've done and put them in
the digital library and disseminate them
and make them available to global
audience for wherever long and so we've
done some work on this and distributed
editing from our perspective or hoping
over the next year to open up every text
that we serve in Perseus in our digital
library to decentralize editing by
anyone in the world you know who really
wants to do a good job that involves
includes fixing typos adding variants
adding linguistic annotation at a markup
doing a whole bunch of things that are
really the fundaments fundamentals of
Digital Editions or the necks of the
successors the modern into print
editions but this is fundamentally a
decentralized task
and you know everything it's all up for
grabs
okay so let's finish up here so what are
they what are some of the implications
for this so one of the things I find
really interesting and this gets back to
the question of the the the role of
elite institutions and is what happens
well what's the best way of
demonstrating what you've learned and is
it saying I got a you know I was group
one at Harvard or whatever you call it
here I was an A student at this snooty
University and these famous people wrote
letters for me what does that really
mean we all know that an a a means very
different things depending on and very
smart you find the people often some
people work smart yet can get AIDS not
doing very much work and it's it's kind
of an imperfect metric and there's a
great deal to be said for having
students focusing on creating portfolios
stuff that they present to the world to
document what they have learned and what
they have contributed one of the things
about NSF fellowships these days is that
they if you sit in a panel I haven't
been on one recently but apparently they
look at your grades say yeah a that's
fine and they look to see what research
you did and to see what you've
contributed to your lab and what kind of
project you have how many humanists are
prepared to compete in that space even
the kind of education we deliver so an
e-portfolio might contain here are
sentences analyzed of Greek analyzed in
our great tree banks with people with
students names on them and they've been
there are three two people annotated and
then one person checks it and the three
of them get credit and you know so
here's your other people who contributed
and ultimately should go to click on the
names and see what they did and so on
here is an e-portfolio for a medieval
Latin class was done with our library
and a colleague of mine where students
produced translations and which they
showed their parents and so on in the
world here's the home were molting
texts where students are publishing you
know the best data there is on the
Homeric manuscripts in blogs support
about the Center for Hellenic studies
and then finally things like when I was
an undergraduate
we had a reading list in classics for
Greek and Latin Yale I believe is the
last apartment standing here Harvard
Brent ran up the white flag and as a
whole thing about reading lists but it's
a way but I could talk about it
basically it's a way of assessing
documenting how much of a language you
know an examination list but we've never
known what it meant and so here this is
they you know this documents is you read
through Greek how many words you've
encountered how many how well how big
your vocabulary is but it's also dynamic
so you could define your own reading
list you could have students say well
you want to learn medieval Latin okay
you got to get giving a reading list of
a hundred thousand words and we'll talk
about what the distribution should be in
the only we couldn't examine that we
couldn't assess that efficiently people
were jammed into canonical you know
small reading list now a lot of this
stuff is is personalizable customizable
okay so to finish up so what are the
implications for Yale and similar
institutions if or as eportfolios
increasingly document what students have
accomplished and contributed I almost
took a job at a wonderful Midwestern
state school I wish I could have taken
it but personal things kept me in the
East Coast and they were they were very
proud of the fact that they are not East
Coast elite institutions that they
deliver education to in an again it's in
a much more egalitarian way and in their
view a much more socially constructive
way than we do at private institutions
in the Northeast that's and they are
ready they're looking forward to
challenging us and if they have an
opportunity to go beyond brand and and
focus on learning that's that changes
the world then okay so this is we're
really looking at for humanists often
what seems to be a radically new a
deeply traditional form of Education
where students are not just examination
guinea pigs getting some subset of a
hundred percent this is actually
200 years old kind of depressing and
amusing at the same time this is the
humble vision of the University and so
they'll conclude with three questions so
or three make three statements we need
to ask ourselves what are we trying to
achieve and those of you have tenure you
can do whatever the hell you want I mean
that's the point but you should think
about what you're trying to treat what
do you really want to do is it just is
it writing books and articles and
teaching people were 18 to 21 or PG
teaching people to teach people were 18
to 21 is that your goal it could be
that's what our goal has been and one
thing is there's just too too much work
for advancement sergers and library
professionals when you have we've
recovered more than a billion words of
Latin from the first million books in
the Internet Archive the whole corpus of
Latin is like 40 million words however
what I'm going to do with this stuff we
need people to help translate annotate
interpret and that's accessible good
undergraduates and we can't depend
solely upon Western voices if you're
looking at the ancient world as a system
there are not enough people and we'll
never be in the seeable future not
people in and in the usual suspects you
know of Western universities to provide
the coverage for classical Chinese for
Sanskrit for classical Arabic these are
partnerships and that doesn't mean they
come you bring people here who speak
English and you know dress and French
clothes or whatever it act like you know
are assimilated this means talking to
people wear turbans in the holy city of
Qom who are not going to be westernized
and they're going to thank you very much
and we're very good have a great Greek
tradition so this is and this is you
know a dialogue across boundaries of
language and culture and one you know
it's and it's not arbitrary is not it's
not you know it's not sort of a dreamy
thing when people storm embassies and
drag and bastards out and kill them
that's a form of dialogue that's you
know dialogue gone gone mad the only
answer to hateful speech is more speech
and it's a long-term process like you
need broccoli not smoking you know but
it is an element of helpful of the
health of society in a globalized world
and those of us who study the past that
member dinosaur that was dragged out
because of stuff that happened a
thousand years ago have a urgent and
constructive and tangible role to play
in abled by technology not driven by
technology with which thank you very
much